in einer halben stunde von köln nach
berlin oder von münchen nach hamburg
club soll das möglich machen das
transportmittel der zukunft jetzt bei
klicks um science-fiction ihnen musk der
gründer von tesla motors und space xvi
palop zunächst in kalifornien starten
damit will macht nichts anderes als das
transportwesen revolutionieren was eine
raumfahrt oder bei elektroautos
geschafft hat will er jetzt auch bei der
weiterentwicklung von
massentransportmittel erreichen
mit einem heber lob könnte man so
schnell reise wie mit der zeit keinem
anderen verkehrsmittel zum
personentransport mehr als 1200
kilometer pro stunde soll möglich sein
und so funktioniert's man benötigt
zunächst mal einen tunnel der dazu
geeignet ist darin ein teil vakuum zu
erzeugen dafür sorgen pumpen die die
luft ab dadurch verringert sich der
luftwiderstand für die transport kapseln
das spart energie und das ist der trick
bei haifa luke welcher antrieb übrigens
später mal den finalen hyper lob an
tragen soll ist in den bisherigen
spezifikationen noch nicht enthalten der
halbblut kann also ähnlich wie ein
moderner ece mit elektrischen motoren an
schienen rädern sein oder auch wie der
transrapid magnetschwebetechnik die
wände des tunnels sollen aus bis zu 25
millimeter dickem stahl bestehen es soll
verschiedene kapseln geben für personen
und zu lasten
man soll sich ein wenig wie in einem
flugzeug darin fühlen und 28 leute
sollen dann platz finden vergleichbare
projekte gab es übrigens auch schon
früher der transrapid den kennen wir
oder die swiss metro das war ein
geplantes projekt in der schweiz bei dem
eine magnetschwebebahn durch
unterirdische tunnel für einen schnellen
personentransport sorgen sollten
das projekt wurde allerdings gecancelt
es war am ende einfach zu teuer
das mag auch daran gelegen haben dass
die tunnel eben unterirdisch durch
unglaubliche bergmassive gebaut werden
sollten das soll beim hyper loop anlass
seien hier sollen die röhren
über die erde das soll nicht nur kosten
beim bausparen sondern auch für die
energiegewinnung nützlich sein oben auf
dem tunnel lassen sich zoller
solarpanels installieren und die pfeile
an denen die höheren montiert sind
sollen windräder seien
damit soll es möglich sein mehr strom zu
produzieren als der hyper loop selbst
verbraucht beim bremsen soll ebenfalls
energie zurückgewonnen werden
man nennt das rekuperation der bau des
hyper loop soll günstiger sein als
andere ähnliche projekte durch ahlborn
chef von hyper luke transportation
technologies sagte in einem spiegel
interview
die kosten liegen bei etwa 20 millionen
dollar pro meile
das sind also etwa 12 4 millionen euro
pro kilometer zum vergleich ein
kilometer transrapid strecke wurde 2002
mit 40 millionen euro pro kilometer
veranschlagt zitat ende
kritiker bemängeln allerdings dass die
baukosten viel zu gering bemessen wurden
design bei anderen projekten zum
beispiel neben dem transrapid zu beginn
auch viel zu niedrig angesetzt worden
einen weiteren kritikpunkt stellt die
sicherheit darf bei den hohen
geschwindigkeiten sei der bremsweg der
kapseln viel zu lang
bei mehr als 1000 kilometern pro stunde
nämlich fast zwei kilometer auch die
evakuierung der insassen aus den röhren
sei es schwierig das geplante
sicherheits konzept überzeugt die
kritiker noch nicht vollends
nichtsdestotrotz sollen die bauarbeiten
für eine acht kilometer lange
teststrecke im kings kantee county in
kalifornien 2016 beginnen und 2017
abgeschlossen sein
zur ersten testfahrt soll es dann ein
jahr später also 2018 oder spätestens
2019 kommen für diese teststrecke sind
kosten in höhe von 150 millionen dollar
kalkuliert worden
die vision der konstrukteure ist den
arbeits und lebensraum der menschen
individueller zu gestalten so soll es
kein problem mehr sein draußen auf dem
land zu leben und trotzdem jeden morgen
eine lange strecke zum arbeitsplatz in
die stadt zu fahren
karl born formulierte so unser
arbeitsplatz legt fest wo wir wohnen
unser wohnort wiederum entscheidet
maßgeblich wen wir lieben ein
transportmittel wieder hyper lob würde
diese zusammenhänge komplett auflösen
ich könnte außerhalb von berlin leben
und trotzdem innerhalb von zehn minuten
in der stadt sein oder ohne große
anstrengung eine fernbeziehung führen
zitat ende die teststrecke entsteht
übrigens in prey valley eine planstadt
die sich komplett mit solarenergie
versorgen soll sorgt soll den leuten der
technische fortschritt auch in form von
vergnügungsparks näher gebracht werden
der hyper lud könnte dann zum transport
der touristen eingesetzt werden noch
sind aber nicht alle genehmigungen für
die stadt eingeholt das soll aber anfang
2016 erledigt sein
der hub sollen nach den plänen seiner
erfinder nicht nur energie effizienter
und kostengünstiger als herkömmliche
verkehrsmittel zu bauen sein sondern
auch bei den fahrtkosten die konkurrenz
weit hinter sich lassen
karl born rechnet vor für eine strecke
von san francisco bis los angeles also
für etwa 600 kilometer bräuchten wir im
schnitt nur 30 dollar als fahrpreis um
innerhalb von acht jahren profitabel zu
sein zitat ende
zum vergleich ein flugticket für diese
strecke kostet rund 100 us dollar
angeblich haben auch schon die ersten
städte interesse am projekt hyperdoc
bekundet würdet ihr mit so einer bahn
zur arbeit fahren und würdet ihr sogar
einen arbeitsplatz hunderte von
kilometern entfernt von zu hause
annehmen wenn ihr trotzdem nur wenig an
fahrzeit hätten schreibt sie in die
kommentare
vielleicht ist das ja wie das internet
etwas was die ganze welt zusammen
wachsen lässt und es wäre ein riesiger
vorteil also diskutiertes jetzt
dranbleiben fürs nächste video
abonnieren nicht vergessen kostet nix am
liebsten auch einen daumen hoch würde
ich mich tierisch darüber freuen und ja
bis dann bleibt dran